there are signs of a breakthrough
tonight in kutz alberta after days of
disruption near the u.s border our
heather urex west is there and joins me
now heather what's happening tonight
donna i can tell you that the situation
here looks a lot different than it did
earlier today protesters have moved
their vehicles to the shoulders opening
up a lane of traffic in both directions
though rcmp say that travel is still not
recommended quite yet still it is a very
hopeful sign here after a very tense few
days
this is what we're trying to get through
oh my god
cell phone video captures the moment of
impact coot's resident tara chamber had
just left town to get groceries when she
was hit it was terrifying absolutely
terrifying the crash happened tuesday
afternoon as rcmp moved in to try and
dismantle the illegal blockade at the
coots border crossing
police warned protesters that if they
did not leave peacefully arrests would
follow a few did leave but then we had
a bunch of vehicles and farm machinery
that were to the north at a roadblock
that was set up on highway 4 to the
north
those vehicles breached the roadblock
and they did that by
driving at quite high speeds it was one
of those vehicles that hit tara
chamber's car police say her husband was
then assaulted before the driver left
the scene all we were doing was going to
go get groceries
and they're trying to say that this is a
peaceful protest
it's not very peaceful to me on tuesday
alberta's premier urged protesters to
end the blockade while calling for calm
anybody who feels sympathetic
to those engaged in this blockade please
stay away from the area
please do not further intensify an
already difficult situation
the police have a job to do
beyond the rcmp checkpoint several dozen
protest vehicles gathered wednesday
their drivers telling global news
they've come in a show of support for
those still here our intention remains
to
restore movement of goods and vehicles
on the road
but
not at the risk of public safety
and rcmp tell me that that group of
protesters beyond the rcmp checkpoint to
the north of here has grown in size so
that is something that rcmp are still
watching very closely right now but
again some hopeful signs as this
blockade uh is in its fifth day donna
all right heather urich's west near the
u.s alberta border